the days pass slowly here there isn't
much to do but clean cook and wait
these rohingya refugees have been at
this temporary shelter in Northern
Indonesia for more than six months
the boat Journey was difficult we had
enough food in the beginning until it
ran out we floated on the water for a
month and the engine stopped working
luckily we received help from another
boat when we arrived I didn't even know
where we were
here many rohingyas say they finally
feel safe after years of living in
crowded and increasingly dangerous
refugee camps in Bangladesh
and before that escaping widespread
Violence by security forces in Myanmar
there are 19 children here under the age
of five living at this temporary shelter
Kitty many of the parents here told Al
Jazeera their only hope is that their
children can get an education and have a
better life than they did
the refugees have their basic needs met
here they're somewhere safe to sleep and
enough food for everyone health workers
visit the shelter several times a week
we cannot say their living condition in
Arches ideal but I guess this is the
safest place for them at the moment but
Indonesia is not home for the refugees
they cannot legally work here and it's
difficult to send their children to
schools a Southeast Asian Foreign
ministers meet in the Indonesian Capital
Jakarta human rights groups criticize
the failures of the asean regional
organization
asean is really unwilling to deal with
this crisis and you know this goes back
a long way I mean we've been seeing
rohingya boats making these perilous
boats Journeys you know for more than a
decade now and you know what we've seen
is a maritime game of ping pong where
you know country is simply Force boats
back out onto the high seas and don't
want to take responsibility
there's even the occasional dance class
intended to be a chance for rohingya
children to make friends with their new
neighbors
for muhusana such festivities are a rare
welcome distraction she and her four
children have no passports no money and
no plans for the future
we were in a similar prison-like place
before and it's the same here so there's
no hope I want to go to a country where
my children can find peace
lately she says she's starting to doubt
whether such a place exists
Jessica Washington Al Jazeera RJ
Indonesia